le coup de filet dans les milieux
islamistes
le gouverneur encore philippe errera qui
assurent la sécurité dans l'est
et à 30 la menace de grève pour le début
notre direction d'enfance gouvernement
découvert par des chercheurs
britanniques certain d'être humains
souvent mais quand tu vois que j'officie
un moyen de cacher la catastrophe une
coulée de boue qui a ravagé plusieurs
villages
l'union l'ampleur de la tragédie à
vannes l'association est exclu au
programme solidarité
madame monsieur bonsoir après le coup de
filet réalisé hier en france et dans
quatre autres pays européens le ministre
de l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement
nous déclarait il hier soir ici même
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une simple
opération préventive et sans vouloir
créer une psychose de l'attentât
il demandait aux français d'être
vigilants pendant toute la période de la
coupe du monde de football le
gouvernante son côté ne reste pas
inactif puisque le plan vigipirate de
surveillance des principaux lieux
publics est d'ores et déjà renforcé ce
sont 6000 policiers gendarmes aidés par
des militaires qui assureront chaque
jour la surveillance du territoire
thierry curtet patrick becker
le plan vigipirate avait été mise en
sommeil c'est ici au pied de la tour
eiffel que l'on constate les premiers
effets de sa réactivation une compagnie
soit une centaine d'hommes d'un régiment
d'artillerie est venu renforcer la
surveillance ou sites habituellement un
mot de postes de police assurent la
sécurité de ce haut lieu touristique
les renforts permettront d'améliorer les
dispositifs et de le rendre opérationnel
24 heures sur 24
celui ci sur la toile pour deux raisons
parce que celle ci comportant également
car vous le savez c'est par trois
importants pour tout ce qui est
télécommunications la tour eiffel est en
effet un réémetteur des images de
télévision c'est donc un objectif
stratégique pour un événement aussi
médiatique que la coupe du monde
de nombreuses autres points sensibles
qui doivent assurer la bonne marche de
l'événement seront ainsi discrètement
protégée
le plan vigipirate n'avaient jamais été
levées mais il est renforcé là où ils
existent notamment dans les gares et les
métros au tout mille militaires seront
déployés dans les prochains jours ils
s'ajouteront aux 800 déjà en place et où
6000 policiers et gendarmes de prévu
l'appel de jean pierre chevènement à la
vigilance les puces a d'autre part été
entendus
il a eu raison de faire ce vaccin aux
événements cela qui est en danger
constat critique visiblement ce qui se
passe autour d'eux qu'est ce que ça peut
apporter quelque chose
le plan vigipirate concerne les villes
où se joueront les matchs mais aussi les
dix départements français qui accueille
déjà les équipes nationales comme chez
les mâles qui reçoit elle seule sa vie
l'autre menace qui pèse sur le bon
déroulement de la coupe du monde de
football et de toute autre nature c'est
la possibilité d'une grève des pilotes
d'air france qui porte toujours sur le
problème des salaires des préavis ont
été déposés pour le début du mois de
juin est pour l'instant ni le pdg du
groupe ni le ministre des transports ne
sont parvenus à trouver un début
d'accord qui pourrait éviter c'est arrêt
de travail dont les conséquences sont
évidents une crime qui intervient au
moment où air france annonce pour la
première fois un bénéfice de son compte
d'exploitation et la commande de vingt
airbus
damien thévenot familles perdent ils les
avions d'air france aux couleurs de la
coupe du monde seront ils cloués au sol
c'est en tout cas la menace que brandit
le snpl le principal syndicat des
pilotes de ligne a en effet déposé un
préavis de grève de 15 jours
renouvelable à partir de lundi prochain
la rencontre hier soir entre le ministre
des transports jean claude gayssot et
les pilotes n'a rien donné
pour les syndicats la situation est très
claire
si l'agression s'arrête avant la coupe
du monde nous arrêterons notre conflit
c'est l'agression continue au moment de
la coupe du monde
le ferons a confié ce qu'il considère
comme une agression c'est la décision
prise par cet homme
jean cyril spinetta le pdg d'air france
s'est donné comme objectif de faire
économiser 500 millions de francs à la
compagnie cela passerait soit par une
baisse de 15% des salaires des pilotes
compensé par une distribution d'actions
et france soit par un gel pur et simple
des rémunérations inadmissible selon les
pilotes pas d'autre solution répond la
direction qui avance un argument avec 60
mille francs de salaire mensuel après
dix ans d'ancienneté
les pilotes français sont mieux lotis
que leurs collègues européens
peu importe la nature et l'ampleur de ce
spectacle a existé mais à partir de là
il faut évidemment sur un marché
complètement concurrentiels n'est certes
pas de se mettre au même niveau que les
autres mais de rapprocher faire
converger le coup à l'extinction
complète
les syndicats ont fixé un ultimatum à la
direction elle a jusqu'à dimanche soir
pour revenir sur sa décision
au delà les pilotes prévisions m
difficile à noisy juin mois de toutes
les galères à air france et à l'occasion
ce conflit les pilotes qui l'on reproche
vous le voyez leur rémunération ont mis
au jour un certain nombre d'emplois de
cadres de la direction d'entreprise dont
la réalité ne leur semble pas évident
parmi eux le fils du maire de paris
dominique tiberi olivier caroff jean
vilar monde
des salariés à qui on ne demande pas de
se serrer la ceinture certains à air
france en connaissent selon le syndicat
national des pilotes de ligne plusieurs
dizaines d'employés serez payés à ne
rien faire dans l'annuaire interne du
groupe on trouve notamment dominique
tibéri le fils du maire de paris
mais difficile de savoir ce qu'il y fait
exactement mais chut il est une personne
ne l'a rencontré à air france qui est
assez surprenant
on nous a confirmé qu'il était toujours
payé on nous a confirmé que son numéro
de téléphone et est la cellule de
mobilité vers france et quand les
salariés ont appelé la cellule de
mobiles temps on leur a confirmé bien
évidemment que jamais monsieur tiberi 1
étaient présents dans l'entreprise
dominique tiberi ne serait-il devenu un
employé fantôme la question se pose mais
depuis plus de deux ans à l'époque
air france le paient sans qu'ils aient à
travailler pour le groupe et pour cause
il était membre d'un cabinet ministériel
une fois cette anomalie révélé tout
était rentré dans l'ordre
air france avait été remboursée et
semblait avoir mis fin aux contrats de
dominique tiberi depuis il a été
réembauché augmenté mais toujours sans
affectation précise il est normal que
l'entreprise essaye quand même de
l'ensemble vocal de leur entreprise une
fonction une place difficilement trapèze
rôle restant à définir emploi fictif
le syndicat national des pilotes de
ligne a décidé de demander à la justice
de tracer la limite entre ces deux
notions on pourra fictif encore cette
fois-ci à la mairie de paris le journal
le monde qui près cet après-midi sur la
possibilité d'une mise en examen d'alain
juppé qui fut premier adjoint du maire
et secrétaire général du rpr ajoutant
qu'à l'elysée une cellule de crise avait
été créée pour traiter cette affaire
information aussitôt démentie par la
présidence de la république
quant à alain juppé dans un communiqué
s'est indigné de ces allégations
affirmant qu'elle était destinée à
troubler la sérénité de la justice
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
n'a pas voulu sanctionner aujourd'hui le
procureur de la république d'evry
laurent davenas ce qui a publié un livre
dans lequel figurent en annexe le
rapport controversé de voavy ribéry pour
le compte du conseil général de
l'essonne dossier dont il est saisi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
entend défendre la liberté d'expression
de ma vie ce pas mais avec des limites
conclut le communiqué
l'assemblée nationale débat du projet de
loi sur le cumul des mandats projet est
contesté par l'opposition dans sa forme
actuelle mais qui ne fait pas non plus
véritablement l'unanimité dans la
majorité qui s'apprête pourtant le voter
en fait les parlementaires estiment que
la limitation des mandats doit
s'accompagner d'une revalorisation
financière pour permettre aux élus de
vivre d'un seul mandat
on partage d'idées guyot yasmina élu
député il y à peine un an
lionnel luca est un assidu sur les bancs
de l'assemblée mais aujourd'hui l'élu et
repère rester à villeneuve-loubet
le débat sur le cumul des mandats agace
particulièrement le conseiller général
député maire un cumulard dans l'âme j'ai
été élu deux mois sans l'investiture de
son parti aux élections législatives
c'est bien la preuve qu'on considère
qu'il vaut mieux quelqu'un qui cumulent
des mandats avec et efficace plutôt que
d'avoir quelqu'un qui ne fait qu'une
chose les mâles maire d'une commune de
15000 habitants lionnel luca a apprécié
le contact avec ses concitoyens
écoutez n'a pas changé c'est d'habitude
pas de chauffeur pas de voiture de
fonction
mais dans cette rue qui donne de la
crédibilité des vrais comme maire d'une
petite commune le fait que je sois
député me fait être considérées
différemment par un certain nombre
d'administrations c'est à dire qu'on
écoute avec plus d'attention que si je
n'étais pas d'écouter men et lucas ne
sais pas quels membres à il préférerait
conserver s'il doit pencher en faveur de
la mairie il quittera les bancs de
l'hémicycle pour retrouver les bancs du
lycée permanent député socialiste henri
bertholet
depuis le temps également de rendement
dans la drôme le militant socialiste
qu'il est condamné bien évidemment le
cumul excessive des monnaies mais il a
conscience aussi quatre maires et
députés très bien souvent
complémentaires et donc plus efficace
c'est quelque chose qui est
intellectuellement extrêmement
gratifiant et ce à titre nombre
intellectuellement
quand on est député maire émile bien
dans sa peau d'un côté le maire de
renouer un contact avec le terrain mais
de l'autre le député renconter ministre
essam aux comptes
difficile de choisir je m'y habituerai
très vite
mais derrière ce projet de loi il ya les
rémunérations que l'on soit député
moulères les salaires sont loin d'être
les mêmes imi votre député le député et
choisiraient de stresser des khmers
permet aux 10000 francs et percevrait
encore un peu plus
rencontrant des prix tels celui qui
promet le froid confrères on passerait
tout à coup à nîmes il avant de voter à
l'assemblée nationale henri bertholet ne
sait toujours pas quel sera son choix
le gène du champion existe-t-il des
chercheurs anglais ont mis en évidence
après expérience sur l'être humain
un gène de prédiction entre guillemets
qui permettra de déceler sur simple test
la probabilité de devenir plus endurant
plus résistants à l'effort que la
moyenne
bref de réunir toutes les chances de
devenir un athlète de très haut niveau
caroline glorion claude sicard dans le
sport la graine de champion
il est ce qu'on repère un entraînement
il y aller surtout l eco sport et les
autres jusque là vous savez ou en tout
cas on l'observé aujourd'hui une équipe
de chercheurs britanniques apporte des
résultats scientifiques passionnés qui
font la preuve de cette inégalité
ils viennent de mettre en évidence les
propriétés d'un gène qui serait
responsable en grande partie de
l'attitude allons durant ce bien
précieux nous sur le terrain on
l'observé depuis très longtemps que les
facteurs qui améliorer notamment la
résistance la puissance cardiaque était
due en grande partie à l'hérédité et
puis à l'entraînement aux facteurs de
récupération au sérieux dans la vie on
peut être le meilleur au monde
physiquement et être rénové sera saine
compétition
c'est seulement palier largement
supérieur le gène étudié par les
britanniques et le gène de l'enzyme de
conversion les couverts lille à 10 ans
par une équipe française qui travaillait
sous des malades se fondent infarctus
pour poursuivre ses travaux les
scientifiques ont étudié les
performances à l'entraînement d'un
groupe des militaires de l'armée
britannique
les résultats sont sans appel ceux qui
sont porteurs du fameux gène multiplie
par plus de 10 sur capacités sportives
les autres ne progresse pas du tout
c'est la première fois que l'on voit un
gène qui intervient tant dans une non
pas dans une susceptibilité à une
maladie mais dans une performance est
quelque part derrière cet intérêt
scientifique
ça m'inquiète beaucoup plus que cela
parce que un monde où certains morceaux
nous serait déterminé non par son droit
inaliénable à la liberté n'est par le
seul droit que lui laisse ses gènes est
un compte que j'aurais le très
considérablement l'utilisation de tels
résultats impliquent d'une de nouvelles
questions éthiques
exemple si un jour
biens fabriqués industriellement la
protéine produite par ce fameux gènes
qui sera alors la porte ouverte à une
nouvelle forme de des pages près de
béthune dans le pas de calais après 48
heures de fouilles dans une maison
habitée par une famille de marginaux les
enquêteurs ont procédé à une série
d'incarcération pour crimes et
complicité de meurtre plusieurs membres
de cette famille ont subi des sévices et
les gendarmes recherchent toujours les
corps de trois bébés qui aurait pu être
enterré dans ce jardin
marianne mastre dominique de cuisine un
matin et zone interdite autour de la
maison et rien à [ __ ] des ballet de
pelleteuses
cette personne est ici 7 - une le père
souffre douleur de la famille il vivait
dans une cabane du jardin en l'an
dernier trois enfants avait déjà été
mise en examen pour violences
volontaires et écrouée
la violence y côtoyer le sordide parmi
les trois mises en examen
et quand tu clos témoignage de patrice
ya 25 ans qui a déclenché les foules
elle aurait accusé ses frères de l'avoir
mise enceinte à plusieurs reprises et
les voir enterrer les corps des
nouveau-nés dans le jardin
aujourd'hui les deux frères ont été
brièvement conduit sur les lieux puis
ramené en prison contre la mère âgée de
67 ans elle vient d'être mise en examen
pour non empêchement de crime et
complicité de meurtre elle est
soupçonnée d'avoir couvert les viols de
sa fille par quel propres chiffres
aujourd'hui les coûts n'ont rien donné
mais peut-être les langues de ton tel
délit
ce soir tous les membres de la famille à
l'exception du père ont donc été écroué
des mises en examen devraient encore
tomber soit pour violences et viol
complicité ou un empêchement de crime
une famille qui vivait à l'écart du
touch au bord d'une nationale au bout du
monde
trois semaines après la catastrophe
survenue dans le sud de l'italie mines
coulées de boue balayant plusieurs
villages sur son passage nous sommes
retournés sur les lieux pour constater
avec le recul
l'ampleur du désastre dans la seule
ville de sarno qui a fait 150 morts
on partage alain job trois semaines
après le drame tard nos pensées prix
et les peler ce sont ces traînées noires
dans la montagne le lit des torrents de
boue qui ont emporté sur leur passage
dans la nuit du 5 au 6 mai trois
semaines après on se rend mieux compte
encore de l'ampleur du désastre
les coulées non pas simplement envahi
les rues et les maisons
elle est détruit anéanti complètement
des quartiers entiers qui ceci était
habitée depuis les pylônes là bas
jusqu'ici il y avait des maisons qui ont
été complètement rasée
cette maison est la seule à avoir
survécu dans ce quartier avec elle les
36 personnes qui s'y étaient réfugiés
son histoire n'est pas banale elle était
à une centaine de mètres là au pied de
la montagne et a glissé du musée 15 à la
maison n'a pas eu le temps de réaliser
ce qui se passait ceux là ont donc eu de
la chance et cherche aujourd'hui dans
leur maison ce qui peut encore être
sauvée car la plupart des habitants du
quartier ne peuvent que constater en
compagnie des pompiers l'ampleur des
dégâts et ont touché et pourtant ils
sont déjà 15 cents sur 4000 à être
revenu et ne songe pas si ce n'est les
riot vie dans les ca comme au japon ou
en californie nous n'avaient aucune
alternative au st ou rester cinq lots
qu'ils plus en est en état d' alerte et
louison de peur de peur et pendant que
la vie continue
les sauveteurs pompiers et militaires
pour l'essentiel creuse et creuse encore
pour rechercher les morts qui use
qu'il faut absolument trouver nous
cherchons en cherchant toujours en
espérant les retrouver car les femmes et
les enfants
le veulent car en campanie comme partout
pour faire son deuil
il faut un tri et au cimetière de
sarnaut à côté des tombes nouvellement
refermé il y à celles qui attendent la
norvège au secours de la russie pour
tenter d'éviter une catastrophe
écologique en effet à mourmansk
principal port de guerre de la marine
nucléaire de l'ex union soviétique
mediène donne à lire toujours dotés de
leurs équipements nucléaires sont
laissés à l'abandon faute de moyens
financiers mais on imagine aisément le
risque encouru non seulement pour les
deux pays mais pour la planète tout
entière
moscou les gilles rabin la toute
première des charges nucléaires qui va
être prêté
après l'accord entre la russie et
norvège la boisson cette banderille rk
en face de la base qui abrite les six
plus gros sous marins nucléaires du
monde sera presqu'île de mourmansk
quelque 40 kilomètres seulement de la
norml l'égard du radier des vieux
réacteurs nucléaires hors d usage
étaient empilés dans ces silos
rudimentaire sans précaution était et le
sont encore
après avoir longtemps démenti la russie
reconnaît aujourd'hui que sont ceux d
amour menthe 9 coeurs de réacteurs
nucléaires
95 sous marins nucléaires aussi hiromi
dans les baies de la presqu'île près de
trente mille éléments irradié sont
éparpillés tout autour sur terre et sous
la mer
la norvège a quelques raisons de
s'inquiéter a déclaré boris eltsine en
accueillant le roi harald 5 à moscou on
ne saurait mieux dire
à la sortie du premier entretien boris
eltsine a été encore plus direct et plus
expliqué la russie n'a plus besoin de
ces vieux sous marin nucléaire
il était temps de venir et il était
temps d'agir
mais ce n'est qu'un tout premier petit
pas la russie ne peut pas financer seuls
la destruction de son énorme arsenal
nucléaire
voici d'ailleurs comment elle détruit
les missiles de ces sous-marins
nucléaires en tirant dessus avec
d'autres missiles et les hommes blessés
de la mer de barrage se referme sur les
débris irradiés ou pas le génocide du
rwanda en 1994 qui avait fait 800 morts
ne doit pas retomber dans l'oubli
c'est ce qu'a décidé le gouvernement de
kigali alors qu'en france une mission
d'information parlementaire cherche à
établir la responsabilité éventuelle du
gouvernement france sur place qu'on va
me de prisonniers sont toujours en
attente d'un jugement
les autorités ont décidé de créer un
mémorial du souvenir et ce mémorial
eh bien il n'aura pas à être construit
il existe déjà une école en l'espace de
48 heures soit cinq mille personnes ont
été massacrées eric monier philippe yon
cela devait être une école technique
elle n'a jamais été inauguré
il ya là des objets des femmes les
hommes tous on souhaiterait en vrac qui
ont été tués et puis ils ont d'abord été
enterré au bulldozer 27000 184 le nombre
des martyrs de l'école morumbi déjà
retrouvé exhumés des fosses communes
locke 27 1184 sur les 60000 tout signe
venu trouver refuge ition exécuté
mi-avril 1994 le massacre et du les deux
jours les miliciens extrémistes hutus
ont dans certaines écoles et on tâte et
à la mitrailleuse à la grenade à la
machette pour ceux qui tentent elles
fuient de cette école le gouvernement
rwandais veut faire un mémorial du
génocide
1 une ambiance déjà un gardien emmanuel
mouret le dira le gardien chaque jour
seuls avec des moyens dérisoires
il lutte contre le temps la
décomposition des corps veiller sur ces
morts très désormais son travail très
mission celle pour laquelle les manuels
en est persuadé la mort a refusé de le
prendre
emmanuel est l'un des quatre seul
survivant de l'école de mourant ici j'ai
reçu une balle pour moi m'a protégé j'ai
réussi à me traîner jusqu au burundi où
on a pu me soigner il ya ici le 28
membres de ma famille mes propres
enfants un plan mais ce n'est pas une
seule de mes filles qu ils sont là oui
on ne peut pas les identifier
alors emmanuel elle choisit de les
garder tous d'être ce gardien des morts
ce guide ou comme il le dit omor qui
parle pour témoigner il troisième gène
cible de ce siècle
au moins huit cent mille morts il ya
quatre ans au rwanda en son temps le
danemark avait une première fois refusé
le traité de maastricht avant qu'un
second référendum souvenez-vous décide
du contraire cette fois-ci toujours seul
en europe et danois votre pas nouveau
demain pour devenir s'ils sont oui ou
non d'accord sur le traité d'amsterdam
qui élargit encore elle les compétences
des institutions européennes un vote qui
s'annonce serré dans ce pays de 4
millions d'habitants
gérard griesbeck projets matures journée
solennelle et refrains bien connue des
centaines de fans sont venus pour le cas
chez les jeunes qui crient sont longues
célérité qui déclare qu'elle ne
partiront pas son la barbie au balcon il
est là le prince charmant
frédéric à 30 ans il règnera un jour sur
le royaume du danemark une grande
famille en quelque sorte s'est attaché à
ses valeurs et que l'ouverture sur
l'europe inquiète un peu loin de la
foule l'ambiance plus feutrée de la
faculté des lettres
à quelques jours des examens de fin
d'année ici aussi on se fait l'écho du
scepticisme ambiant sur nous mêmes
nomique c'est une bonne chose l'union
européenne mais il ya quand même autre
chose ici et j'ai encore que la dame à
30 millions la campagne électorale est
un peu terne
pourtant le gouvernement mais aussi la
presse à une exception près très engagés
en faveur du oui jusqu'à cet industriel
importateurs et exportateurs de vins
français pour toute la scandinavie
il a planté le drapeau européen sur nos
toits de son bureau et pense que si le
nous l'important ce sera une catastrophe
je suis sûr que ça sert à une grand choc
les danois parce que je trouve je dois
connaître à prague nerfs comme hollande
la belgique la france l'espagne et
maintenant est un peu fatigué pour le
danemark et prochaine millions les
autres payer plus travailler sans la
marque puis l'allemande danemark est un
petit royaume où rebelles et les gens
ici en sont fiers mais c'est aussi un
des plus grands exportateurs au monde
denrées alimentaires et son marché c'est
l'europe
alors entre la fierté politique et la
nécessité économique
il faudra bien choisir demain forte
chute de la bourse de paris aujourd'hui
- 2,39 % à la clôture après la journée
record d'hier ce sont les mauvaises
nouvelles venues d'asie et qui sont à
l'origine de cette chute on a enregistré
une baisse sensible des bourses de hong
kong et de bangkok en thaïlande
l'insee communique ses statistiques sur
le revenu brut moyen des exploitations
agricoles en 97 une hausse moyenne donc
de 6% céréaliers viticulteurs sont les
principaux bénéficiaires de ces
augmentations
une nouvelle chaîne de télévision a
commencé d'émettre installé au coeur du
20e arrondissement de paris elle a été
créée par le dal l'association du droit
au logement en pointe vous le savez dans
tous les récents combats contre
l'exclusion sociale
cette chaîne propose des émissions de
services mais elle est aussi très
militant ce chef pirate fait déjà
l'objet d'une plainte du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel reportages et
m6
on les voit là bonjour et bienvenue
sauver c'est faux nous prenons l'antenne
depuis les toits de paris
c'est une réquisition de fréquence
depuis l'autre soir en toute illégalité
de nouvelles télévisions en équipant de
cet immeuble symbole à lui tout seul des
années 80 propriété de bulles crise du
crédit
laissé à l'abandon et finalement investi
par l'association pro les trente ans
après mai 68 avec du matériel de
récupération
les militants compris qu'aujourd'hui les
slogans que ce cri sur internet et au
mieux encore sur une télé pirate
forcément un peu provocatrice on a envie
de diffuser des images que l'on voit que
l'on voit nulle part que les télévisions
traditionnelles france 2 françois tf1 et
les autres ne passerait jamais et je te
retrouves pense essentiellement
l'ensemble des luttes d'élus qui
s'inspire surtout qu'est ce qu'on
appelle l'exclusion même si je n'aime
pas trop ce terme les lieux des mal
logés et des sans papiers bien sûr
l'ascenseur est en panne et il faut
gravir les douze étages à pied pour
accéder à un bureau autrefois
directorial est aujourd'hui transformée
en studio une sans frontières c'est son
nom les nas mais volontaires sont donné
les moyens d'être non seulement une
telle vision militante
même si la proximité donc fermer sa
recette depuis 26 ans et ça fait traquer
des enfants le plus sécurisé de sa
lettre au nombre de coups de fil pour
cette première soirée sur le canal 36 ce
fut un succès est militant à convaincre
les deux millions dé téléspectateurs
potentiels de l'est parisien de réécrire
avec es folle ans 2,68 brève puis
évolution et gagnent révolution les
autorités n'interviennent pas d'ici là
effectivement il y a trente ans très
exactement le 24 mai 1968 a été signé
après plusieurs journées et nuits de
négociations les fameux accords dits de
grenelle qui aboutissait à une
augmentation de salaire substantielle et
à des changements importants dans la vie
de l'entreprise enfants en 68 le
mouvement étudiant avait précédé le
mouvement ouvrier
mais c'est la fin des grèves et des
occupations d usines qui a marqué leurs
tours à la norme bailly michel angles la
science c'est tout ce que le général
redoutée elle était bien là c'est allé
sous les yeux de tous depuis dix jours
la chienlit parc transport
approvisionnement coupé essence
rationner la france était paralysé 10
millions de grévistes du jamais
surveillé maître des lieux sont partent
aussi de la parole bien parti nantes
affiche où le drapeau rouge flotte trucs
sur le seront de l'industrie française
mais ce qui glace le pouvoir par dessus
tout c'est 7 février d'étudiants qui
menacent de tunis
si georges séguy le leader de la cgt et
daniel cohn bendit parvient à s'entendre
c'est la fin assurés du régime gaulliste
certains l'avaient bien coupe à partir
de l'homme il fallait à la fois décroché
le mouvement social du mouvement
étudiant et pour cela il fallait faire
en sorte que les syndicats et des motifs
de recommander la reprise du travail
et c'est ce que ce souffle le conseiller
balladur à son patron georges profits
augmenter les salaires la cgt ne peut
qu'applaudir
autoriser légalement les syndicats dans
l'entreprise lasserre d'été sont faits
les filtres à améliorer la condition
ouvrière sur les chaînes de montage
réduire le temps de travail dans
l'automobile embauché des intérimaires
les solutions pour sortir du conflit
inimaginable une semaine auparavant
semble alors possible avec une priorité
humaniser de monde du travail
paul roux cela un ancien de renault
flins parle aujourd'hui de l'avant 68 à
l' usine comme d'un autre siècle
tout le monde a vu les temps modernes de
charlie chaplin longue son tapis avec
d'effectuer dans la main j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir une scène dans le
bâtiment de mécanique à l'assemblage du
moteur avant sa bosse sous la caisse
un ouvrier avait deux clés à faux dans
les mains il travailla les huit est que
charlot n'atteignez parra était vraiment
inimaginable
le sourire du cnpf une face à la
pression est forte
il va devoir lâcher alors ce 27 mai jour
qu'un accord de bonnel le smic au plan
de 35 % les autres salaires de 10% 29
heures de négociations et pourtant le
droit syndical dans l'entreprise et aux
rythmes et styles
nous avons atteint un résultat de
première importance et qu'il doit
permettre la reprise du travail dans des
conditions aussi rapide que le fermer la
technique la reprise jean resseguié
poule par les ouvriers arnaud comme
ailleurs ils poursuivent l'occupation
des usines ce qui est un gros plus fin
juin
retour à la normale les trente ans plus
tard les acteurs de l'époque regarde ce
qu'il reste des acquis de melle usine
bilan d'étape c'est pire qu'avant 68
actuellement ceux qui ceux qui sont
actuellement l'intérieur de l'entreprise
vous diront que via un chantage
permanent qui s'exerce sur eux c'est la
peur qui s'installe contenu et du
chômage dans la boue si t'es pas content
tu la trouves tu t'en vas en trouvant ce
qui a changé et je pense qu'il s'est
appuyé vers cible même ils tous accès le
comportement des individus
quand j'ai entendu si plus entre
l'énergie encadrement et 10,1 les
ouvriers ont ce qu'ils soient commandés
la tâche en saas a changé d'époque tu
nous parler de la même manière
aujourd'hui le bastion de billancourt
est fermé depuis 68 l'industrie
française a licencié deux millions de
salariés
mais le pays n'a jamais plus comme une
autre général pour les majeurs qui se
posent aux détenus sortis de prison
c'est souvent le manque de formation
professionnelle et l'espoir de trouver
plus ou moins rapidement un travail
depuis quelques années miam centre de
détention de bédenac en gironde
expérimentent ce que l'on pourrait
appeler une forme de retour progressif à
un travail à l'extérieur la prison un
groupe d'une quinzaine de détenus vient
ainsi de participer pendant un an et
demi à la restauration des vestiges du
château de montguyon reportage axe vital
philippe duval
noël comme ses quatre compagnons est un
prisonnier en formation pro métiers
c'est la maçonnerie il a donc choisi la
rénovation soigneusement sélectionnés
tous ces détenus sont en fin de peine
aujourd'hui au petit matin ils piquent
la prison pour le château de longuyon il
travaille avec des consignes bien sûr
mais sans surveillance je vais essayer
de finir pour me dire parce que après
midi il faudrait qu'ils soient gratter
chez la semaine prochaine ce avec
courant sera vite arriver au 31 mai pour
la fête inaugurale
tout ici a été restauré par les détenus
du centre de bézenac ici muraille
connaissent aujourd'hui une véritable
résurrection
c'est une colline boisée en aubry
absolument rien et en rhénanie grâce à
lui aux employés de l'association il ya
eu 700 m² l'embarquant été restauré
bénévolement et au moindre coût pour le
côté technique les travaux étaient
estimés à deux millions de francs ils
auront coûté vingt mille fois en réalité
bien sûr l'administration pénitentiaire
a fait un pari risqué mais s'il est
d'abord guidé par la logique classer les
gens devant leur responsabilité de les
préparer à la sortie de leur promettre
dans leur métier d'origine et de prouver
aussi également à la population et à
l'administration que chad marshall
dernière est l'homme qui était capable
de faire un métier d'hommes alors sorti
chacun des détenus revint à diplôme de
formation retenu par la chambre des
métiers
un argument de plus pour leur
réinsertion s'il doute de l'accueil des
entreprises
certains patrons considérer qu'on était
détenu mais bon on a payé notre dette
c'est une réhabilitation et je pense que
c'est aux futurs employeurs de notre
confiance en attendant chaque soir ils
regagnent le centre de détention alors
de l'appel la vraie sortie pour plus
tard parallèlement la coupe du monde de
football se déroulera la coupe du monde
des banlieues des équipes d'adolescents
venus du monde entier
à l'origine de cette manifestation saint
denis la ville du stade de france
cet événement ne serait pas simplement
sportif mais un moyen pour les jeunes
d'apprendre à se connaître
c'est pour cette raison qu'un groupe
d'adolescents 2 5 me est parti vers le
canada à rendre visite à nos lointains
cousins reportage ou et cars ou hmida
il s'appelle christophe harold luan et
de yassine moyenne d'âge datant tous
issus de sa venue et les anglais
ambassadeur pour la coupe du monde et
beaulieu tous volontaires pour
représenter leur ville et rencontrer les
jeunes de montréal avec chacun d'eux
blick et les biens personnels pour leur
vie alors qu il doit aussi à la paire
comité impôts des français un côté
américain cela est géré par les lois
fédérales et ian binnie de la baume s'il
ya une chose qui me tient vraiment à
quel titre elle jusque là dessus des
jeunes filles veille
le premier objectif de cette coupe du
monde des banlieues s'était amené les
jeunes moyennant une participation 2030
à découvrir comment l'on vit la musique
le tout les aussi la recherche d'un
emploi ou l'oratrice à montréal par
exemple dans le car près de la côte des
neiges chômage drogue petit de la pop ce
quartier a un air de déjà vu
ici les habitants sont en léger à
wingles et dahir l'occasion pour les
jeunes français de découvrir les limites
il mélange ethnique à la canadienne
l'étude qui tient une bande compacts à
gros contrats comme les loups n'a
commencé que j'ai jamais par la n 10
comme ma vie jamais lu un ami ou encore
et si la durée de son contenu à une
culture et n'est pas vrai ce qu'on dit
que nous on a toutes les sections autre
lieu autre réaction
plus exactement la faire mieux après
j'attends destiné à la réinsertion des
jeunes toxicomanes et nouvelle visite où
les discussions et les jeunes français
de réagir quand le modèle canadien
ensemble protecteur j'ai posé la
question à plusieurs québécois de mon
âge qui était leur premier c'est notre
caca sur la vie sociale
j'aborde et tan tan qui enflamme le mont
royal une fois par semaine jeune
français et québécois ont quand même
pris le temps d'échanger quelques passes
avant de se retrouver à tenir aux mois
de juin et le bénéfice de ces rencontres
de rassembler beaucoup plus longtemps
une partie des comptes
roland garros l'invité du jour que l'on
attendait pas que l'on redoute est c'est
la pluie qui a troublé les parties peut
même qualification facile en trois sets
du chilien marcelo rios face à
l'espanyol alvarez qualification
également de martina hingis de venus
williams de borno votre marque ou de
votre marque chez les femmes en revanche
défaite ce soir du français guillaume
raoux ce est en ce moment même le numéro
un mondial sampras en difficulté devant
le jeune espagnol delgado il a perdu les
deux premiers sets sans passe et il est
mené 4 2 dans le troisième set après le
succès mondial d'andrea bocelli son
équivalent féminin et mâcha plein une
française de 23 ans confirme comme la
révélation musicale de cette année une
cantatrice à la voix très belle mais
aussi très particulière olivier les nz à
christophe il m'a chaplin une demoiselle
hors du temps et garé dans un opéra fin
de siècle
j'ai rencontré mes chats place et c'est
pas sa voix qui m'a frappé parce que
maintenant mais une cassette en me
disant faut pas écouter ce type et il a
fallu jarre enfoncé quatre ans plus tard
on compte mais on peut travailler sa
voix nous attendait 'cela ne veuille
plus justement parce que je fais une
mission à force de persévérance la
protégée de capdevielle a trouvé sa voix
soprano dramatique les leviers une
passionnée de chant lyrique à vous payer
un temps au hard rock avant de chanter
en italien du 14ème siècle la langue ou
bill et de pétrarque et de plantes pour
fin au concours au prêt à donner une
dimension supérieure quelque chose de
grand galet représentant chorale de ça
donne une ambiance une atmosphère de
quelque chose qu'on puisse pas classés
lors d'une époque prise par je n'ai pas
envie qu'il est contre cette école
à 23 ans et main coûte au succès ou
schibli zh mais sort elle est toute
autre
l'opéra groupe comme le jeu de comédiens
universel et puis des décors des
costumes
pourquoi pas les peintures et la chaplin
qui admire la callas
la diva qui représente à ses yeux
perfection la sienne direction des
forêts travailler afin de se produire
sur les plus belles scènes du monde
comme ici à venise sur un strict plan de
cuivre ces deux clans antique et miles
aucune et a pu lier le ton de légende du
roi arthur des consciente astiquer des
vampires
ces créatures assoiffées de sang qui lui
aussi le temps vous incarne pour moi
l'élégance absolue
ce sont des êtres fragiles passionné et
puis ils voyagent à travers les époques
avant de nous quitter le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi d'abord la tribune aux
fumerolles après le confinés par les
forces de sécurité de la france menace
de grève pour le début de la coupe du
monde se précise pilotes directeurs de
compagnies gouvernement n'ont toujours
pas trouvé de terrain pour la zone a
cependant la météo sophie davant je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne bonsoir alors